it's hard to tell these days between a
real movie kiss and one created with
visual effects trickery from extra
cautious safety protocols to the
convenience of using body doubles here's
why so many actors choose to fake it
when smooching on screen
Thor the Dark World sees Thor's corner
of the MCU fall into crisis hundreds of
years after the asgardians defeated the
dark elves Jane Foster played by Natalie
Portman finds a powerful weapon called
The Ether which uses her as its host
Thor played by Chris Hemsworth must
protect her from the dark elf malekith
before he captures her and uses The
Ether to wreak havoc on Earth during the
after credit scene Thor returns to Earth
with the day saved and malekith gone he
shares a passionate and celebratory kiss
with Jane surprisingly Hemsworth didn't
actually kiss Portman during the scene
she wasn't able to make it to the
reshoots so producers decided to use a
body double and shoot the scene from
behind they gave Hemsworth a list of
body doubles to choose from but
Hemsworth chose his wife Elsa Pataki
instead she dressed up as the character
ran up to him and they locked lips if
that isn't romantic we don't know what
is
you people follows new couple Ezra and
Amira as they deal with the cultural
differences between their families after
they say their wedding vows they lock
lips and flower petals fall around them
some might consider it the most romantic
moment in the film but comedian Andrew
Schultz who plays Ezra's cousin Avi
revealed that the kiss was actually
created with CGI Schultz said while
co-hosting the brilliant idiots podcast
the final scene they don't even kiss is
CGI why didn't they go in for a real
kiss in short because of kova 19 safety
guidelines filming took place in 2021 so
they had to maintain a safe social
distance to help prevent the virus from
spreading
accomplished firefighter Caleb Holt
played by Kirk Cameron realizes that his
marriage to Catherine played by Aaron
Buffet is falling apart with the
encouragement of his father he reads a
Christian self-help book called The Love
Dare and embarks on its 40-day challenge
to save his relationship but Cameron is
a devout Christian and won't kiss any
woman besides his wife Chelsea Noble to
film the scene without compromising
Cameron's values filmmakers had Noble
dress up as Catherine then shot the
scene in silhouette Cameron explained to
today the reason this movie was
important to me personally is because I
love my wife dearly we've been married
for 17 years and we have six children so
marriage is a very special and sacred
thing to us it is my great privilege to
love and cherish exclusively my
beautiful wife in the end fire proof
affirms these beliefs Caleb and
Catherine find a way to work things out
lots of romantic movies feature Happy
Endings but few incorporate real world
romances in such a unique way
Will Smith Rose to popularity as the
star of The Fresh Prince of Bel Air but
he proved he could also take on serious
fare when he accepted a leading role in
Six Degrees of Separation in this film a
rich couple's lifestyle is disrupted
when a mysterious man named Paul played
by Smith visits their home claiming to
be their children's friend Paul uses his
charms to take advantage of them but his
lies are eventually exposed Smith was
committed to the role but there was just
one problem he didn't want to kiss
Anthony Michael Hall who played Trent a
student with a crush on Paul right
before they were going to film a kiss
scene Smith told the director he
wouldn't do it ultimately they had to
use a stand-in and shoot the scene from
behind Smith told Entertainment Weekly
it was very immature on my part I was
thinking how are my friends in Philly
going to think about this I wasn't
emotionally stable enough to
artistically commit to that aspect of
the film though he was undoubtedly angry
with himself for refusing to follow
through he went on to say that the
experience was ultimately worthwhile
because it brought him valuable insight
there's nothing like getting cozy under
your favorite blanket with a cup of hot
chocolate and settling in to watch a
romantic holiday movie but during the
pandemic holiday movie Giant lifetime
had to figure out how to film kiss
scenes while still keeping people safe
this led to an interesting solution in
Christmas ever after this movie follows
romance novelist Izzy Simmons who was
plagued with writer's block as she
arrives at a bed and breakfast for the
holidays the Inn's owner Matt looks just
like the main character of her books
Izzy is finally able to overcome her
writer's block as they fall in love Amy
Winter head of programming at lifetime
discussed making the movies kiss scene
happen with the rap remarking everybody
was incredibly concerned about making
sure that we were following the best
possible guidelines to keep people safe
and the greatest oddest solution I've
seen so far is people kissing through
Plexiglas that can be removed in post
that's just what they did for Christmas
ever after though the behind the scenes
photos might look odd the finished kiss
is Just as romantic as holiday movie
fans could want
Call the Midwife follows the midwives
nurses and nuns of nanata's house as
they help London families during the
1950s and 1960s in season 11 widower
Matthew gets closer to nurse Trixie and
the two eventually share a kiss it's
incredibly romantic but things were much
more Awkward behind the scenes due to
kova 19 safety protocols Helen George
who played Nurse Trixie told radio times
we became Masters at kissing through
perspex it's probably the most unsexy
thing you could ever do a man comes
along with a little spray and a window
wipe and wipes away our spit after every
take horrific she went on to say there
were a few takes it takes a while to get
there it was so mechanical we turn our
head to the left or bring your cheek in
a bit or your head awful awful so
embarrassing it's safe to say that
George wasn't a fan of kissing through
perspex but kudos to her and her co-star
for powering through these scenes their
characters have a special bond and fans
would have been very disappointed if
they didn't end up kissing
Freddy is a short-lived 2000 sitcom
following Freddie Moreno played by
Freddie Prince Jr Freddy is a chef who
takes in his older sister niece
sister-in-law and grandmother after
times get tough women wear your women
things
how where the man thinks the show's
opening sequence features numerous
Freddy clones interacting with many
different characters they make out with
women argue with Grandma and help
Freddie his niece with her homework
visual effects supervisor Jeff Oaken
explained to VFX Blog the premise here
is that Freddy is all things to all his
family and friends they wanted a main
title to reflect this so the show's
creators came up with the idea of having
Freddy continually clone off into a new
Freddy for each person's needs to create
the multiplying Freddy smooching the
visual effects crew created a mishmash
of partially real and partially fake
kissing first the crew filmed Prince
actually kissing the actress after that
they did another take with Prince
pretending to kiss her so he could play
the part of the different clone that
splits off at that moment okin said we
used the Frozen video to position him to
match himself that way the Clone would
start on the movement of splitting apart
and all we needed to do was use an
articulated wipe to reveal the new
Freddy it took many tries to get
everything lined up properly but in the
end they pulled it off
EastEnders is a long-running soap opera
exploring the drama-filled relationships
between the people of London's East End
and what would a soap opera be without
plenty of kissing scenes filming
intimate moments during the pandemic was
a challenge however luckily the crew
found multiple ways to get around this
issue while still following kova 19
protocols in 2020 executive producer
John sen told Sky News for those really
crucial moments where two characters
Kiss we've actually invited the
real-life partners of the actors onto
the set to be able to cheat those kind
of moments these scenes were also shot
from specific angles to obscure the fact
that body doubles were used this wasn't
the only bit of clever trickery the
creators of EastEnders employed to film
scenes involving characters who live
together producers use perspex to make
close proximity covet safe at other
times they used plate shots which
combine separately filmed actors into
one coherent shot
British soap opera Coronation Street
follows the working-class residents of
weatherfield England as they navigate
Family Life romance work and various
personal issues during the pandemic
producers had to figure out how to film
a scene in which Tyrone played by Alan
housel and Alina played by roxandra
porogenico share a kiss they managed to
fake the lip block with the help of Alex
Mulvaney a regular extra on the show and
his wife Hannah Mulvaney told the BBC
during a 2021 interview my agent said
that Coronation Street needed extras my
partner Hannah hadn't done any extra
work before but my agent knew she had
dark hair like Alina's so I asked her if
she wanted to do it despite some initial
nervousness she's a big fan of the show
Hannah was up for it to create the
non-cissing parts of the scene hausel
and pora jonico were each filmed
separately because they couldn't gaze
into each other's eyes the actors looked
at a pair of sunglasses taped to a pole
once everything was filmed visual
effects artists brought these disparate
shots together into a coherent hole
in this long-running Australian soap
opera the residents of Ramsey Street
face challenges involving work love
their pasts and much more like many
other shows filmed during the pandemic
the makers of neighbors didn't want to
exclude kiss scenes leading them to
explore unique approaches Colette Mann
who plays Sheila canning revealed one
way they made the smooches happen each
actor kissed a mirror then the visual
effects team worked their magic making
it seem like the characters were kissing
each other smooching a mirror isn't
exactly romantic but hey crazier things
have happened on soap operas before for
the scene in which Pierce Grayson played
by Tim Roberts kisses dippy rebecci
played by Sharon johal the neighbor's
crew left the mirror behind and brought
in johal's husband as Joe Hall told
Harold's son she even made him practice
the night beforehand I thought my
kissing skills were up to scratch but
obviously not Joe Hall's husband Encore
also remarked she told me it was more
for blocking so she was experimenting
with different angles the pandemic made
lots of couples do weird things but this
is definitely one of the strangest
plan a plan B centers around Matchmaker
Dr narali Vora played by Tamina who
opens up a business next to cynical
divorce lawyer cost of chagule played by
ritesh Deshmukh they constantly butt
heads but have so much chemistry that
they end up falling in love though
Deshmukh refuses to do on-screen lip
locks the two characters manage to have
a lengthy kiss scene filmmakers made
this happen by using certain camera
angles to create the appearance of
kissing without Deshmukh and Tamanna
ever actually making contact some
viewers find the postmuch convincing but
others think it looks laughably fake why
the deception fans speculate deshmuk
believes kisses are meant to be private
moments between two people
Lindsay Lohan and Charlie Sheen don't
play the leading roles in Scary Movie 5
but they still have some funny moments
together on screen
cabin to film a racy tape they make the
adults only entertainment with gusto but
in truth no actual kissing takes place
according to TMZ Lohan was supposed to
kiss Sheen multiple times but refused to
do so allegedly she made this stance
clear well before filming took place but
changes weren't made until shooting was
set to commence rumor has it they
brought in a body double and did what
they could to cut unnecessary kiss
scenes out of the script entirely does
this result in a convincing scene your
mileage may vary but you're probably not
judging a scary movie installment based
on its convincing smooches
foreign
[Music]